es un vídeo que confirma el temor de
muchos a mercenarios del grupo Wagner
izando su bandera en bahamut mientras
bailan e incluso tocan la guitarra En
referencia a su apodo los músicos no se
sabe la fecha del vídeo pero el líder de
la milicia lo compartió este jueves con
un propósito bajar la moral de las
tropas ucranianas en una batalla de
desgaste que se ha prolongado por meses
Hola a todos primero de marzo me
gustaría decir que hemos silenciado un
poco al enemigo ahora todo está un poco
más tranquilo pero si escuchan hay un
tiroteo en las afueras seguimos firmes
en bahamut nadie planea retirarse a
ninguna parte por el momento bahamut es
Ucrania
[Música]
pero los informes no son tan optimistas
se indican que este jueves las tropas
ucranianas intentaban aferrarse a sus
posiciones ante la avanzada de la
ofensiva rusa que ya se ha saldado con
cientos de soldados heridos y también
civiles
solo a unos 10 kilómetros del frente los
ciudadanos que quedan en bahmud escuchan
la Ráfaga de ataques
algunos estaban decididos a quedarse
Pero al final han tirado la toalla
porque temen por su vida nos vamos nos
quedamos hasta el último momento
queríamos quedarnos el apartamento de
nuestros vecinos ha sido destruido es
hora de irnos si Rusia consigue hacerse
con bakmuth esta sería una victoria
clave para Moscú ya que las ciudades
clave en la ruta de abastecimiento de
Ucrania en las últimas semanas los rusos
se han hecho con localidades de
alrededor como soledad o crianza hora